but one thing i have noticed like i have
to ask though true crime
so so for every girl's intuition
so recently i recently we've caught up
and you started talking about your
newest obsession and
some of your new content which uh is
very a true crime-esque you know
you've released we've recently released
a video on the otaku killer
um i found it funny because we hadn't
talked for a while
and uh sydney also very much went into
this phase and she
i mean she's like serial killers for a
lot of times but
um but now but now but now it seems like
every girl is into true crimes and true
crime probably so you want to see from a
female's perspective
why why what happened i like true crime
and i i i don't really know why i like
true crime no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no i
just find really
i i find that [ __ ] fascinating as [ __ ]
but there's a difference between
liking the content and it being the
first thing i watch
you know i i did ask one other girl
sorry before you answer i didn't want to
this made me laugh a lot i asked why do
you like true crime they're like oh it's
like preparation
to defend myself in case this happens
and i'm like
yo how often are you going to come
across a serial killer who specifically
duct tapes like 10 victims together
yeah yeah because it was funny because
like um you know being with sydney for
so long she's from wisconsin and one of
one of the things they're apparently
proud of is that there are so many
killers that have come from wisconsin so
isn't it like the number one state like
the most amount of serial
so she had always prided herself on like
you know i am
i'm the serial killer otaku and then
suddenly in like the past year or two
every girl started getting into serial
killers and true crime and i'm just here
thinking
where did this come from where did it
start honestly i feel like just the
blow-up has happened because true crime
youtubers
specifically criminal psychology just
started getting recommended and it's
like
awoken something i think we all really
like because for me i never thought of
this as a girl thing until like you told
me
uh when we met up and then i was like no
that's not a thing and then
you know then the next day like i just
remember like
charlotte like texted me she's like yes
you're coming up we're gonna watch the
true crime stuff i said yeah oh my
[ __ ] god
this is the thing so so for me
personally i always thought it just came
from me really liking horror and then i
that just and me taking psychology i
love the reason i loved
serial killer stories is not what they
did but it's like
the psychology that goes through it
because serial killers have a very are
a lot of them are very intelligent and
the [ __ ] that they have to do to get to
that point is it's almost like the more
i read it the more i don't want to think
it's real
it seems like it's just so stranger than
fiction it's so strange so that's where
that's why i liked true crime and then
like with the
the youtube channel criminal psychology
i just like it that someone had
you know the patience to take like the
raw interrogation and break down
why they ask these questions because you
can't help but applaud some of these
like
um interrogators that they do this for a
living and they know exactly what
questions to ask you
not for you to answer but to just see
how you're going to respond like
sometimes they leave you alone just for
you to stew in your own thoughts and
i just and garmin's laughing at this
because i was like i sometimes feel like
when i watch it i'm the one being
interrogated
like i feel like i have to lie myself
out of this i'm just watching the
[ __ ] thing
but yeah so then i started the true
crime stuff in japan because
in japan i've always just thought you
know there's always a thing everyone
knows that crime is really low in japan
but when [ __ ] happens in japan it's from
like zero to a hundred it's like
in in america it's nothing like this
weird take this with a grain of salt
normal
like guy kills girlfriend for cheating
on him right it's not that it's like
i'm going to like burn everyone alive
and like post it
like on 2chan just because i feel like
it and it's like nothing builds up
between that so
my true crime stuff is like i want to
look back of what the [ __ ] happened to
this it's like an episode of black
mirror sometimes
essentially yeah you know in in the us
they might assume that it could be
something bad that's happened right
because you know crime doesn't happen
that much i think the police never like
think to
that this guy might be going after
i've also noticed that with at least
japanese like true crime
a lot of like uh i guess people in japan
don't talk about it because they don't
like it
yeah it's like no don't forget it let it
be yeah so it's really interesting
seeing like people
i like yourself trying to find stuff out
about it because it's like so buried
because they don't want to talk about it
yeah yeah
pretty much and so i'm freaking out i
completely forgot
again like but then like i totally get
the obsession
in that right and i totally get like you
know watching these interrogation stuff
super fun yeah but like there's a
difference again between like
you know looking at an interrogator
doing his job and being like wow the
psychology behind this is [ __ ]
fascinating
and you know [ __ ] waking up like
seven in the morning and you just
from the living room you just hear his
arms
her eyes were a gouge and i go in i'm
like what the [ __ ] happening you're
just like sitting at the table eating
cereal like
like it's nothing that's just our
mornings i was like bonding with joey
over there to be like
did you wake up to true crime podcast
yeah and you're you're going to listen
to two kind of podcasts because i do
yeah
yeah yeah yeah charlotte's telling me
i'm just like the sunlight is coming
through the birds are chirping it's a
lovely day and
you just hear like and and so he
brutally murdered these girls in the
most gruesome way possible here's how
they did it number
10. number 10 remember we even went up
in the to the north and we uh we were
meeting sharla
and then like you guys wanted to go to
bed but she's like uh like
hey guys i'm going to go upstairs does
anyone want to watch the true kind thing
with me i'm like i'll do it
and then she's like all right let's go
literally yeah
yeah me and my friend was just like all
right see you later have a nice day i
don't know it's just like
because it's just people talking and
well no i'm not awesome yeah but then
but then at the same time right it's
it's it's the it's the
double-edged like thing of like you know
what the girls will be like yeah we love
watching true crime but then
when you tell a girl that you know you
watch the two-hour frederick newson down
the rabbit hole video they'd be like why
would you watch this
yeah like bro they're amazing like what
do you mean
meanwhile it's like yeah i don't know
what's a two hour down the rabbit hole
upside down i am going to go with a
six-hour
yeah it's like with some guy
commentating over it
like button like shut the [ __ ] up yeah
that means just like i bet he's thinking
about our other girls this is just the
boys watching super monkey balls
did you watch the netflix documentary
about like the uh i think it's like the
hotel it's about like
the yeah the the hotel where they find
the girl in the uh
the water tower oh the water tank one
yeah that's really funny i really liked
that one because it was like you thought
like
it's about this case and they suddenly
were like yeah so about these redditors
man
yeah it was really cool because it
actually like because it was quite
recent
it was like giving you the perspective
of the cops at the time and they were
getting so
frustrated the people online kept trying
to [ __ ] solve the case
right you wouldn't stop coming up with
crazy ass conspiracy theories
and it made me think it was like i was
like oh yeah it must be so [ __ ]
annoying
being a policeman now where everyone is
trying to do your job yeah like
release every detail totally i was gonna
watch that documentary and i brought it
up to akio i was like oh they they made
a documentary about the you know this
case and she's like i already know yeah
she already knows the details
so i never ended up watching it i gotta
ask like because if you consume a lot
how what like where is the line with
youtubers talking about like
real life cases what what i mean like
because do you think it's free game they
can say whatever they want conspiracy
theories and all they can talk about it
like
because it's like kind of rough because
it's like you only have x amount of
facts right
so i went pretty [ __ ] deep with the
otaku killer one
um with that one theories right like you
just told the case yeah because
yeah when it comes to presenting
theories i would say that like
i don't know because for me i want to go
over cases that are already like closed
right right by that point like and it's
been a substantial amount
you don't want to accidentally solve a
case because okay so i don't know if you
guys knew about like you probably heard
of
that twitter killer in japan i didn't
even want to touch that because that was
still going on and i didn't want to [ __ ]
it up
like with my video you know i feel so
bad for these like like in that
documentary as well like the cops and
also the families like
this whole documentary was going on
about this hotel you should watch it by
the way